[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend wir sind noch immer in einer
pandemie die omikron welle läuft um den
globus und türmt sich hierzulande gerade
höher und höher auf gesundheitsminister
lauterbach rechnet erst mitte februar
mit dem höhepunkt der welle heute lagen
die neuinfektionen erstmals über 100.000
dem robert koch institut wurden aktuell
1323 infektionen gemeldet fast 32.000
mehr als vor einer woche die sieben tage
incidents liegt nun bei 584 4 auch das
ein höchstwert aber auf deutschlands
intensivstationen hat sich die lage
bisher nicht verschärft 86 prozent der
betten sind belegt davon zwölf prozent
von corona patienten für das öffentliche
leben bleibt omikron aber eine gefahr
dann wenn zu viele gleichzeitig krank
werden um diese gefahr zu bannen kommt
dem testen vor allem den pcr tests eine
wichtige rolle zu weil sie am ende
klarheit bringen auch ob jemand arbeiten
darf oder nicht mit den steigenden
fallzahlen werden allerdings die test
kapazitäten knapp schon jetzt eva
schiller und konstant zug 1 berichten
wieder eine neue lieferung wieder boxen
voll mit abstrichen wieder mehr pcr
tests zwölf mitarbeiter wurden hier im
ludwigsburger labor geschult um tests zu
analysieren sie machen überstunden und
kaum urlaub weil personal fehlt während
die korona zahlen explodieren
sie müssen sie vorstand dass die die
instanzen dadurch zustande kommen dass
tests gemacht werden ja und daraus
ergibt sich das ja schon dass bei uns
einfach das gruppe aufkommen deutlich
höher ist und das muss das personal
puppen und wir müssen einfach das tun
was notwendig ist und gegebenenfalls
wird anhalt test länger brauchen aber
der kampf gegen omikron ist auch ein
kampf gegen die zeit und wo schnelltests
an grenzen stoßen sind schnelle pcr
ergebnisse umso wichtiger hätte
deutschland besser vorbereitet sein
müssen in wien fährt man seit 2020 eine
komplett andere test strategie man setzt
auf kostenlose pcr tests gurgeln zu
hause das video zur kontrolle hochladen
die probe abgeben im supermarkt mehrmals
pro woche testen sich so kinder und
erwachsene in firmen behörden kliniken
extra für corona eingerichtete riesen
labore werden pro woche mehr als 3,5
millionen pcr tests aus mehr als ganz
deutschland zusammen die erkannten fälle
sind dementsprechend hoch aber dadurch
werden infektionen früh erkannt die
versionen können früher eine absonderung
geschickt werden damit werden
infektionsketten noch unterbrochen
wissenschaftler der uni wien haben die
pcr strategie entwickelt sie auch dem rk
ii vorgeführt eine verpasste chance sagt
michael wagner ich glaube deutschland
hat es zu lange aus einer rein
medizinisch diagnostischen perspektive
engagiert perfekt ist der test dabei
übersehen dass die pcr auch mit google
und polen um grössenordnungen
empfindlicher ist als jeder antigen test
und auch ganz leicht angepasst werden
kann neue variante der pandemie einen
schritt voraus sein in deutschland
fehlen ideen findet auch die tübinger
ärztin lisa federle sie hat sich auf
eigene kosten ein pc er ähnliches
testgerät angeschafft statt das in allen
hausarztpraxen zu finanzieren oder jetzt
sogar der zuschuss für testkits gekürzt
gerade war eine lehrerin mit positiven
schnelltest da nach 15 minuten war klar
negativ sie kann weiter unterrichten wir
wissen dass jetzt eine riesige welle
über uns einbrechen wird und dass wir da
zumindest testen testen testen müssen ja
sonst bricht irgendwann die
infrastruktur zusammen weil das ist
besonders wichtig da schnell zu testen
und nicht fünf tage offen ergebnis zu
erwarten also ich habe kein verständnis
dafür wenn die laboriert an die grenzen
kommen weil wir hatten zwei jahre jetzt
zeit bald sollen ludwigsburg ein roboter
die tests zahl um 20 prozent erhöhen in
deutschland versucht irgendwie ohne
strategie test kapazitäten hoch zu
schrauben pcr test sollen sparsamer
eingesetzt
gesundheitspersonal priorisiert werden
wien macht das genaue gegenteil pcr
tests für alle rund um die uhr das labor
hat die kapazitäten auf 800.000 tests
pro tag aufgestockt
aber landesweit wird auch in österreich
inzwischen eng es ist die pflicht des
staates seine bürgerinnen und bürger vor
corinna zu schützen gleichzeitig muss er
dies mit den geringsten eingriffen in
freiheitsrechte tun eine immer
schwierige balance zwischen sicherheit
und freiheit zumal in zeiten in denen
demokratie feinde die lage für sich
nutzen wollen der bundespräsident
äußerte sich heute besorgt über die
radikalisierung von corona protesten wir
sprechen darüber gleich mit der neuen
innenministerin nancy faeser die sich
auf die fahnen schreibt mit klarer kante
gegen hass und gewalt vorzugehen
zunächst schaut thomas bärsch auf einen
fall in bautzen der dort heute in einem
schnellverfahren verhandelt wurde der 21
jährige constantin l aus bautzen hatte
heute nachmittag vermutlich ein mildes
urteil erwartet ein urteil in einem
prozess gerade mal 16 tage nach der
straftat von dem sich die
staatsanwaltschaft gerade deshalb
einiges erhofft es ist ja ein
pädagogischer grundsatz dass die strafe
nach möglichkeit auf dem fuß folgen soll
und in diesem fall ist es sicherlich
auch eine überlegung dass deutlich
gemacht werden soll das rechtsverstöße
im zusammenhang mit diesen corona
protesten nicht folgenlos bleiben am
dritten januar zogen hunderte durch die
bautzener straßen ja viele friedlich
aber eben nicht alle es flogen böller
gegen polizisten und fäuste auf die
polizei stoppte die menge und bildete
einen kessel irgendwo mittendrin
constantin l die taschen voller
pyrotechnik bei seinem versuch aus dem
kessel auszubrechen bringt der
angeklagte einen beamten zu fall der
mann ist 1 meter 90 groß und 100 kilo
schwer das zeigt die kräfte die hier
wirkten bautzen ist nur ein beispiel
dafür was ich gerade auf den deutschen
straßen abspielt der dauer corona stress
hat ans licht gebracht wie viele der
demokratie und ihren akteuren
grundsätzlich misstrauen
auf den strassen sammeln sich eben genau
diese menschen ja fakten verdrossen
menschen die medien nicht mehr glauben
stichwort lügen presse wissenschafts
skeptiker in die irgendwie keine lust
auf fakten haben oder die
wissenschaftler nicht glauben oder leute
die eben mit demokratischen
institutionen unzufrieden sind oder
deren repräsentant die situation ist
verfahren denn es geht nicht mehr nur um
kritik an corinna schutzmaßnahmen
sondern um ein aufbegehren an sich
dieses dagegen aufbegehren sich als
widerstandskämpfer da vielleicht auch zu
stilisieren mut zu zeigen gegen die da
oben auf die straße zu gehen das schafft
eine vergemeinschaftung die auch nach
außen abschottet und deswegen sehen wir
und jetzt mittlerweile wirklich
tatsächlich schlimme bilder gegenüber
polizisten die irgendwie mit flaschen
beworfen werden mit böllern beworfen
werden was strafrechtlich verfolgt wird
doch bei demonstranten die sich hier in
einer diktatur werden könnten die
beschleunigten verfahren genau die
gegenteilige wirkung zeigen ich glaube
die kurzfristige wirkung wird die sein
dass der frist noch mal wachsen wird die
personen fühlen sich zu unrecht am
pranger gestellt und es ist quasi ein
beweis dafür gebracht dass der staat
nicht mehr demokratisch ist sondern
selbst jetzt vor gericht gegen menschen
vorgeht die ihr recht in anspruch nehmen
wollen friedlich wie sie selbst
behaupten auf den straßen zu
demonstrieren wie constantin l sein
urteil aufnehmen das bleibt sein
geheimnis
acht monate haft zur bewährung
ausgesetzt wenn er sich zwei jahre lang
nichts zuschulden kommen lässt außerdem
muss er 1000 euro strafe bezahlen an
einen bautzener polizeisportverein
und in berlin begrüße ich dazu die neue
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser am
abend guten abend verschossen profesor
wie hoch ist aus ihrer sicht die gefahr
dass sich corinna leugner impfgegner je
länger die pandemie dauert tatsächlich
radikalisieren geräte grundsätzlich was
ins rutschen in unserer gesellschaft ich
würde nicht sagen in unserer
gesellschaft insgesamt sondern bei
dieser kleinen minderheit stellen wir
leider schon fest dass die
radikalisierung zunimmt insofern ist das
etwas was uns natürlich große sorge
bereitet weil wir auch trage sehen dass
rechtsextremisten die
corona demonstrationen für sich und für
ihre eigenen zwecke ausnutzen aber lässt
sich das quantifizieren in irgendeiner
weise wenn der bundespräsident vor der
radikalisierung durch rechtsextreme
waren dann ist ihm das thema ja wichtig
der bundeskanzler sagt aber ja und ich
höre dass bei ihnen auch es gibt im
grunde keine spaltung eben nur eine
kleine ablehnende minderheit
worauf stützen sie ihre befürchtung ihre
sorge jemand stürzt es natürlich auf die
zunehmenden demonstrationsgeschehen und
zahlen natürlich das ist das eine aber
im verhältnis auf die gesamtbevölkerung
ist es ja immer noch eine kleine
minderheit die auf die straße geht und
an die große mehrheit der bevölkerung
die sich jetzt zwei jahre lang an allem
corona maßnahmen gehalten haben die auch
schwierige entscheidungen mitgetragen
haben die werden viel zu wenig erwähnt
und deswegen möchte ich denen auch noch
mal ausdrücklich danken auf der anderen
seite sehen wir eben dass
rechtsextremisten das
demonstrationsgeschehen für sich selber
nutzen und das hat der bundespräsident
auch angesprochen das muss uns sorge
bereiten und da ist ja auch der
präsident des bundesverfassungsschutzes
gerade unterwegs um davor auch zu warnen
und sie auch sie plädieren da auch für
klare kante also für schnellere
strafverfolgung auch wir haben den fall
in bautzen ja heute gesehen da setzen
sie auf abschreckende
abschreckende wirkung
aber das könnte natürlich auch ein stück
weit nach hinten losgehen wenn das
wieder stoff für verschwörungstheorien
wird so nach dem motto ach jetzt geht es
plötzlich also ich glaube es zunächst
mal gut wenn man auch aufzeigt das
fehlverhalten
gewaltanwendung übergriffe auch
journalistin journalisten oder
politikerin politiker oder eben gerade
polizeibeamtinnen und beamten auch dazu
führt dass das konsequenzen hat und je
schneller man die konsequenzen auch
merkt umso besser dann hat das natürlich
auch abschreckende wirkung für andere
deswegen finde ich es zunächst mal gut
mit dieser verfahrens verkürzung auch zu
arbeiten natürlich muss man jetzt darauf
achten dass man nicht den eindruck
gewinnt nur hier wird das so angewandt
ich finde ein verfahren bei solchen
verstößen die sehr schnell aufzuklären
sind dass das generell eine schnelle
wirkung des rechtsstaates auch hat das
wäre sicherlich empfehlenswert wenn wir
von radikalisierten ehrung sprechen
fräser wie weit wird eine impfpflicht
die der gesundheitsminister ja auch nach
wie vor anstrebt für den fürs frühjahr
dazu weiter beitragen
ich glaube solange das diskutiert wird
wird es natürlich auch dazu beitragen
dass menschen mit einer anderen meinung
auf die straße gehen das kann man ja
auch machen das ist auch in einem
rechtsstaat ja durchaus gewünscht dass
menschen mit einer anderen meinung diese
auch auf der straße austragen können was
aber nicht geht ist das eben menschen
auf die straße gehen um gewalt auszuüben
um hass gegen andere dort zu skandieren
und eben menschen dazu diffamieren und
dagegen wehren wir uns so stark und da
wird auch der rechtsstaat mit aller
härte gegen vorgehen solange das thema
ist wird es natürlich auch auf der
straße sichtbar sein aber muss die
politik sich dann nicht doch auch noch
stärker um die kümmern die man
vielleicht noch erreichen kann wer jetzt
noch mal fragen tschechien hat seine
pläne für eine impfpflicht jetzt gekippt
man sehe die gefahr so nicht mehr in
anderen ländern werden schutzmaßnahmen
zurückgefahren in großbritannien zum
beispiel heute die masken pflicht ihr
bei uns wird dafür der genesenen status
auf drei monate verkürzt sich wird
bewusst mal zuspitzen sind das nicht
punkte die jedenfalls dazu auch angetan
sind zweifel zu wecken ob der staat ist
wirklich so ernst meint mit der
zusicherung die ja sie auch geben das
alle freiheitsrechte wiederhergestellt
werden nein ich glaube im gegenteil ich
glaube es wäre gut wenn die impfpflicht
dann auch schnell käme weil ich habe die
überwiegende mehrheit der bevölkerung
angesprochen und die überwiegende
mehrheit der bevölkerung möchte ja diese
impfpflicht auch damit wir für den
nächsten winter ganz anders gewappnet
sind und die pandemie auch endgültig in
den griff bekommen ich finde diese
mehrheit der menschen die hat ja auch
ein recht darauf dass alle
freiheitsrechte wieder zurück gewährt
werden können und vielleicht sollte man
das auch hin und wieder aus dieser
perspektive betrachten und dann finde
ich es eigentlich wichtig bei dieser
linie auch zu bleiben das hat auch etwas
mit glaubwürdigkeit in der politik zu
tun sagt die bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser herzlichen dank herzlichen
dank für chancen
das gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
vor einer stunde aufgezeichnet und hier
geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
außenpolitischen thema dieser woche
gundula gause
im konflikt um die ukraine hat
us-außenminister blinken in kiew seine
diplomatischen bemühungen zur lösung der
angespannten lage fortgesetzt erneut
sagte er der ukraine unterstützung zu
und drohte nach gesprächen mit präsident
selensky russland mit massiven
konsequenzen die us regierung wisse von
plänen des kreml für eine weitere
kurzfristige aufstockung der russischen
truppen an der grenze zur ukraine
morgen wird linken in berlin mit
außenministerin baerbock und den
amtskollegen aus london und paris
beraten
angesichts der krise hat frankreichs
präsident makro eine neue sicherheits
ordnung in europa gefordert gemeinsam
mit deutschland sei er bereit zu
verhandlungen mit russland und der
ukraine vor dem europäischen parlament
war ob er für eine neue
stabilitätspolitik die er im rahmen des
französischen eu ratsvorsitzes
voranbringen wolle auch bei den großen
herausforderungen klimawandel und
digitalisierung dürfe die eu nicht bloß
reagieren sondern müsse stark und
unabhängig handeln
wegen des anfangsverdachtes der untreue
zum nachteil der eigenen partei
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft berlin
gegen den bundesvorstand der grünen
damit auch gegen vizekanzler habeck und
außenministerin baerbock dabei geht es
um die mitwirkung an beschlüssen zur
auszahlung von corona boni 2020 diese
bereits bekannten sonderzahlungen von
jeweils 1500 euro haben die
vorstandsmitglieder
zurückgezahlt die behörde geht nun aber
strafanzeigen von privatleuten nach
wegen des qualvollen todes von 39
vietnamesischen migranten in einem
lastwagen in england sind mehrere
schleuser in belgien verurteilt worden
15 jahre haft erhielt ein vietnamese der
das schleuser netzwerk in belgien
geleitet hatte 17 weitere angeklagte
wurde schuldig gesprochen im oktober
2009 10 waren 39 vietnamesen östlich von
london tot in einem lkw container in
deckt worden gestorben an
sauerstoffmangel und überhitzung es ist
der zweite prozess um starts folter in
syrien binnen kurzem vor einem deutschen
oberlandesgericht in frankfurt am main
muss sich ein syrischer arzt
verantworten wegen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit vor zehn jahren
währenddessen syrischen bürgerkrieges
soll der heute 36-jährige in
militärkrankenhäusern in homs und
damaskus 18 gefangene gefoltert haben
seit 2005 10 arbeitete der mann in
hessen als auch die pegel vor einer
woche war bereits in koblenz ein syrer
wegen ähnlicher gewalttaten zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt worden
vor einem jahr war er es der in den usa
und der freien welt für hoffnung und
aufbruch stimmung sorgte am 20 januar 20
21 wurde josef kabinett beiden junior 78
jährige präsident der vereinigten
staaten damit war bei vielen die
erwartung verknüpft dass er mit seiner
erfahrung die chaotischen trump jahre
überwinden und die usa krisenfest
steuern werde mit ansehen im in und
ausland
doch nach einem jahr im amt sieht beiden
bilanz ziemlich kläglich aus schlechte
umfragewerte und eine reformagenda die
in sich zusammenfällt beiden wirkt oft
nicht mehr erfahren sondern alt und im
hintergrund treibt sich einer die hände
donald trump zum jahrestag unsere
korrespondentin claudia benz
er war angetreten als großer versöhner
in seinem land wo nur noch riesige
flaggen groß genug sind um als symbol
der einheit die zerrissenheit dahinter
zu verdecken
herausforderungen gab es viele aber vor
allem ein ziel die nation zu versöhnen
und damit die demokratie zu retten
heute an diesem januar bin ich mit
ganzer seele dabei amerika zusammen zu
bringen unsere menschen zu einen und
unsere nation zu einen
es ging dynamisch los dem pariser
klimaabkommen wieder beigetreten ein
qubit hilfspaket mit umfassenden hilfen
für die menschen die impfaktion lief
erfolgreich an in jeder drogerie überall
konnten menschen sich impfen lassen und
ein billionenschweres
infrastrukturpaket durch den kongress
gebracht amerika bleibt wettbewerbsfähig
ein großer wurf und doch bei all dem
seine zustimmungswerte im keller
beiden hat viel für die menschen getan
natürlich gibt es dinge jenseits seiner
kontrolle wie inflation und omikron aber
die demokraten haben die botschaft
einfach nicht erfolgreich unter die
menschen gebracht
und dann kamen die großen misserfolge
der afghanistan einsatz endete in
völligem chaos die inflation amerikaner
ächzen unter hohen preisen und zeigen
mit dem finger auf den präsidenten das
herz von beiden plänen sein großes
sozial und klimapaket im kongress nach
viel hin und her erst mal in der
sackgasse und dann ist da der zornige
man im schatten und seine getreuen
partei die alles tun um beiden den
erfolg zu verwehren noch ein jahr nach
dem angriff auf die demokratie zweifeln
70 prozent der republikaner daran dass
beiden die wahl überhaupt gewonnen hat
die große lüge von der gestohlenen war
verunsichert das land die republikaner
haben keine prinzipien die demokraten
kein rückgrat republikaner sind
skrupellos sie werden nichts auslassen
um die macht an sich zu reißen und die
demokraten können sich darin nicht mit
ihnen messen wenn die republikaner das
wahlsystem an sich ziehen werden sie
sogar als minderheit regieren können
die demokratie retten das land versöhnen
beiden selbst beschrieb damals was es
bedeuten würde hier in zu scheitern
ohne einheit gibt es keinen frieden nur
bitterkeit und wut ohne fortschritt gibt
es nur erschöpfende empörung keine
nation nur ein zustand von chaos
das zu verhindern hat er nicht mehr viel
zeit denn die kongresswahlen im november
werfen längst ihre schatten voraus
ja und wir gehen noch einmal live zu
claudia bates nach washington claudia
der präsident will in diesen minuten in
einer pressekonferenz seine eigene
bilanz vorstellen wie will er denn das
ruder jetzt bis zu den kongresswahlen
noch rumreißen
das problem ist dass seine vorhaben
größer sind als seine mehrheiten und da
hat er nun zwei möglichkeiten entweder
er versucht mit macht seine agenda durch
den kongress zu bringen das würde
erfordern dass dort verfahrensregeln
geändert werden das würde er spalten
oder aber er versucht seine vorhaben der
seiner schmalen mehrheit anzupassen
kompromisse zu finden vor allem in der
eigenen zerrissenen partei
möglicherweise noch einige republikaner
mit an bord zu bringen dann wäre das
beiden der versöhner wenn beides
scheitert und er seine vorhaben nicht
durch den kongress bringt dann wird er
seine mehrheiten im november verlieren
wie realistisch ist denn die die
perspektive für donald trump wirklich
wird der ernsthaft versuchen zurück auf
den präsidentenstuhl zu kommen
das sagt er ja noch nicht ganz offen
aber er bereitet den weg er hat
jedenfalls die republikaner die
republikanische partei besser im griff
als in seiner zeit als präsident der
pusht jetzt kandidaten die für die
kongresswahlen die ihm loyal ergeben
sind das heißt er versucht dafür zu
sorgen dass er im kongress dann loyale
abgeordnete für seine politik sitzen
hätte gleichzeitig ist es so dass
möglicherweise auch noch mutige
gegenkandidaten in der republikanischen
partei erscheinen werden die dann
versuchen werden eine ähnliche politik
wie er zu versprechen bei größerer
berechenbarkeit insofern ist das auch
noch eine möglichkeit
dankeschön claudia benz nach washington
ja und meldungen vom sport und zunächst
aus der wirtschaft jetzt von gundel da
ist die hohe inflation das thema das
unternehmen und verbraucher belastet das
statistische bundesamt bestätigte eine
teuerungsrate von im schnitt 3,1 prozent
im vergangenen jahr und damit den
höchsten stand seit fast 30 jahren
valerie ganz wichtig nun wie sich die
preise weiter entwickeln was sagen
experten nun die meisten erwarten dass
der preisdruck nur langsam zurückgeht
eine drei vor dem komma davon gehen
einige aus problem sind vor allem die
schon oft erwähnten lieferengpässe die
halten sich hartnäckig das schraubt die
herstellungskosten nach oben kosten die
viele unternehmen an ihre kunden
weitergeben ja und hinzukommt öl ist
wieder teurer geworden und energie war
ja in den vergangenen monaten der
preistreiber schlechthin er gibt für den
dezember eine inflationsrate von 5,3
prozent
aufs gesamtjahr gesehen sind die preise
in deutschland im schnitt um 3,1 prozent
gestiegen für viele menschen wird der
preisschub zur belastungsprobe
laut einer umfrage im auftrag der
postbank kann jeder neunte deutsche nach
eigenen angaben kaum noch seine
regelmäßigen ausgaben stemmen wegen der
höheren inflation scheint nun auch die
zeit der - zinsen abzulaufen nach langer
pause bekommen anleger wieder geld für
ihre kredite an den deutschen staat die
rendite der zehnjährigen bundesanleihe
ist erstmals seit fast drei jahren auf
über null prozent gestiegen für den
finanzminister aber kein grund zur sorge
zinsen leicht über null kann sich der
staat locker leisten das bedeutet aber
auch dass hypothekenzinsen steigen denn
für die sind die 10 jährigen bunds ein
entscheidender maßstab
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt in
der deutschen handball
nationalmannschaft gibt es weitere
corona fälle betroffen sind drei spiele
darunter sebastian heimann und christoph
steinert die gestern noch gegen polen
mit angetreten waren damit fallen am tag
vor dem ersten hauptrundenspiel der
europameisterschaft gegen
titelverteidiger spanien insgesamt zwölf
spieler aus nach zdf informationen gibt
es aktuell aber keine tendenz dass die
mannschaft aus bratislava abreißt
im dfb pokal laufen die letzten
achtelfinal partien auch heute wieder
mit zunächst einer überraschung
zweitligist hannover 96 gewann klar
gegen erstliga borussia mönchengladbach
3 zu 0 und steht damit im viertelfinale
ebenso wie erwartbar rb leipzig mit dem
2 0 sieg gegen hansa rostock
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
alexander zverev hat bei den australian
open auch sein zweites spiel klar
gewonnen ohne satzverlust gegen den
australier john millman am freitag geht
es um den einzug ins achtelfinale gegen
qualifikant radio albert aus moldau
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
am mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr 7 19
43 45 48 49 superzahl 4 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
dresden trägt heute trauer denn ein
grosser der stadt ist gegangen
hans-jürgen genannt dixie dörner der
dynamo dresden in den siebzigerjahren
großmacht als libero ein regisseur auf
dem platz elegant und mit übersicht
sagen die die ihn spielen sagen er war
ddr nationalspieler drei mal fußballer
des jahres und blieb seinem verein immer
verbunden letzten acht ist er verstorben
andreas weise erinnert an die
lichtgestalt des ddr fußballs
in den hintergrund schwarz dominiert
heute auf der internetseite von dynamo
dresden
trauer um vereins ikone hans jürgen
dixie dörner
den vielleicht besten fußballer den
dresden die in die ddr je hatte über 550
spiele für dynamo dresden jäh fünfmal
meister und pokalsieger 100 länderspiele
für die ddr
größter erfolg olympisches gold mit der
ddr nationalmannschaft in montreal 1976
3 zu 1 im endspiel gegen polen ein team
gespickt mit stars das zwei jahre zuvor
fast der bundesrepublik den titel im
eigenen land verdorben hätte
nach dem finale in montreal gegen die
polen haben wir natürlich zwei nächte
durchgefeiert waren in montreal in der
diskothek und das war natürlich für den
fußballer als auch für mich etwas
besonderes ganz klar
unvergessen die duelle mit bayern
münchen im europapokal der landesmeister
beckenbauer des ostens wurde dörner oft
genannt beide waren libero beide
technisch hervorragende fußballer die
mehr konnten als einfach nur den ball
aus der gefahrenzone schlagen in der ddr
kannten ihn alle unter seinem spitznamen
dixie angelehnt an einem oldtimer wie es
dazu kam bei einem besuch im sportstudio
1996 erklärt er ist ich habe in meiner
kindheit immer mit mit älteren
jugendlichen kindern fußball gespielt
und wahrscheinlich war ich so langsam
gegenüber diesen diesen älteren dass sie
immer wieder taxi gerufen später
arbeitete er als trainer nach der
wiedervereinigung erst beim dfb dann als
erster coach aus der ehemaligen ddr bei
einem bundesligisten bei werder bremen
später stand er noch in zwickau kairo
und bleiben sich an der seitenlinie die
große fußball liebe blieb für ihn aber
immer dynamo dresden der verein für den
er sich bis zum schluss engagiert
sechs tage vor seinem 71 geburtstag
starb hans jürgen dixie dörner letzten
acht nach langer schwerer krankheit
dixie dörner wir geben sie jetzt weiter
anhand pieper und das auslandsjournal
dass sich mit einer politischen
wiederauferstehung befasst jedenfalls
strebt er sie an silvio berlusconi der
es mit 85 jahren noch mal wissen will
und
nachrichten gibt es hier wieder in
unserem heute journal update mit
christopher wehrmann gegen 0.30 uhr
morgens ist schöner
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt bewegung ins
winterwetter und das liegt an der
kombination von diesen beiden tiefs über
skandinavien und dem hoch über dem
atlantik die strömung dreht bei uns auf
nord und deswegen wird es vorübergehend
mal kälter bei uns und auch weniger
schon heute nacht geht der regen
jedenfalls oberhalb von 300 bis 500
meter mehr und mehr in schnee über
machen sie sich also auf gefährliche
glätte gefasst und auf tief winterliche
straßenverhältnisse in den
mittelgebirgen dazu pfeift die an der
nordsee ein starker bis stürmischer
nordwestwind und die temperaturen sinken
auf werte zwischen plus 3 und minus vier
grad über tag zieht der schnee dann
weiter südwärts und am längsten schneit
es noch hier am erzgebirge und auch an
den alpen dahinter entwickeln sich
kräftige schauer schnee schnee regen und
graupelschauer und im östlichen
brandenburg könnte es sogar mal für ein
winter gewitter erreichen entlang der
elbe aber bis hinauf nach
schleswig-holstein scheint die sonne zum
teil strahlend dass es dann der norwegen
fühlen an der küste sind wirklich
kräftig aus nordwestlichen richtungen
ganz anders am alpenrand da schneit es
am längsten und den temperaturen morgen
in zwischen minus ein und plus 6 grad
und den wind schauen wir uns jetzt noch
mal etwas genauer an denn der pfeife
über die nordsee sie sehen das sehr
schön an der roten wand fahre dieser
wird wird uns nicht nur morgen
beschäftigen sondern auch noch am
freitag da wird er dann im nordosten
deutschlands für viel sonnenschein
sorgen sonst geht es einfach nur
winterlich weiter guten abend